dans l'actualité de ce vendredi cette
réflexion qui ne manquera pas de
susciter bien des commentaires et
sûrement des polémiques réflexions de
martine aubry qui envisage d'ici un an
d'allonger à 12 semaines le délai de
recours à l'avortement comme le font la
majorité des pays européens
pour l'instant cette mesure est à
l'étude elle impliquerait un
assouplissement de la loi veulent avec
pour philosophie garantir l'accès à
l'ivg et j'ai françoise valais il y ana
moryoussef depuis la loi de 1975
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est un droit dont chaque femme doit
pouvoir bénéficier dans les meilleures
conditions
mais en raison du manque de structures
dans certains hôpitaux de la surcharge
de travail dans d'autres et parfois du
peu d'enthousiasmé des médecins les
femmes n'ont pas toujours accès à liv et
g martine aubry envisage donc un
allongement du délai légal celui ci
passerait de 10 à 12 semaines comme dans
la plupart des pays européens pour les
centres de planification cette mesure
est importante
chaque année plus de 5000 femmes partent
avorter à l'étranger et une inégalité
des chances face à libérer pour ces
délais là puisque c'est les femmes qui
sont en situation les plus précaires qui
vont être amenés à attendre ou à a pas
se rendre compte rapidement de leurs
étals grossesse je regrette que martine
aubry demande aux hôpitaux publics de
remplir leur mission est d'intégrer la
pratique de l'ibg dans tous les services
de gynéco-obstétrique de france
mais pour la ministre l'avortement doit
rester un ultime recours le plus
important c'est la prévention
la première action que je souhaite mener
pendant cette année c'est une action
très ample de communication pour faire
connaître les nouveaux moyens de
contraception notamment la pilule du
lendemain pour faire connaître toutes
les possibilités offertes par les moyens
de contraception à tous les publics et
notamment aux jeunes une grande campagne
d'information diffusés par la presse
écrite par la radio et la télévision est
prêt je vais à partir d'octobre